what's up buddy
hey rich i've been listening to your uh
videos um
quite a bit lately i just got onto them
about a month and a half ago so thanks
for the content all right all right
anyway i wanted to touch on
um how you were saying like in the
animal kingdom you know depression
doesn't exist
and um because about a year ago i
started getting divorced and uh
you know
therapists and everybody's like oh he's
got depression and just like
i don't know it was
it was dealing with that at first and
then like once i learned the mindset
part and change my mindset i was just
like
it's not a
it's not a diagnosis it's just a way of
being stuck in a certain mindset
it's just a shitty time in your life man
it's like you know okay that's that's
fine you know we all get him it's you
know get up in the morning and grind
again you know
you've you make some stupid choices and
sometimes bad [ __ ] happens um
a lion will chase an animal and trip and
fall and maybe cut its foot you know not
not get the kill you know its feelings
get hurt
does it does it really or does it just
get back up and say you know what i'm
tired and take a nap under that tree
over there i'm gonna try again later on
right like that's generally what the
animal kingdom does but i think that
in society today
we're we're way too quick to like
embrace
the victim mindset and the victim
mindset's a loser's mindset um people
that get stuck in a cycle of of
constantly losing in life i stay away
from them i keep them at arm's length i
will not like i don't even care if it's
a family member man i just won't deal
with them on a long-term basis
right arm's length right you know like
if you just want to keep losing in life
and that's fine
i'm about winning and i want to surround
myself with winners so yeah absolutely
you know like shit's going to happen you
divorce happens bad financial you know
choices happen uh you know you lose
money you get your heart broken you know
check cheats on you whatever you know
like bad [ __ ] happens you know you're a
man is basically what i'm saying it's
like you know you have the burden of
performance just get it done
see i'm saying
definitely
all right thanks for chiming in bob
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you